Folksinger, songwriter, modern-day minstrel; to many baby boomers...,
...Bob Dylan is the voice of their generation.
But his winning the 2016 Nobel prize for literature stuns Stockholm crowd...
...at Thursday's announcement.
Bob Dylan.
Mentioned in Nobel speculation for years...
...but never seen as a serious contender...,
Dylan is the first songwriter to win the prestigious award.
For having created new poetic expressions...
...within the great american song tradition.
And Dylan has created so much poetry for the years.
From "Blowin' in the Wind" to "Subterranean Homesick Blues"...
...to his transformative rock anthem "Like a Rolling Stone."
The Nobel is just the latest honor for this legendary performer.
He's won 10 Grammy awards, a Golden Globe, an Oscar,...
...inducted into the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame.
He's also received a Pulitzer Prize and the Presidential Medal of Freedom.
And has sold tens of millions of records in a career spanning more than 5 decades.